hey everybody welcome back to my channel
my name is samuel leeds and in this
video i'm going to be answering all of
your questions around property
investment and there's quite a lot of
questions last week around hmos a hmo is
a house of multiple occupancy this is
just an absolutely incredible way to
rent a property out on a room by room
basis and receive two or three times as
much rental income however there's
always going to be little problems that
come up and there's going to be
questions around management refinancing
valuations tenants so if you have those
questions
and you're struggling with the deal or
you're just struggling to understand the
concept of a deal whether it be a rent
to rent or a hmo or buying the buying
process the legals
i've done hundreds of hmos over the past
13 years i've bought them i've packaged
them i've sold them i've flipped them
i've controlled them so i'm here on
youtube just literally straight up
answering all of your questions with no
agenda you ask the questions and i'm
gonna answer so if you enjoy my channel
please do me a massive favor and just
help give back it doesn't cost any money
to do this just go ahead and hit the
like button that'd be amazing and then
more people will see this channel and it
will help them in their property
investment journey which is what i'm
about my mission is to help people
invest in property successfully so let's
see what questions we had last week hit
the like button and get commenting your
questions and i'm going to read your
questions and i'm going to answer your
questions on next week's video so go
ahead answer your questions whatever it
might be
okay so we've got a question from waves
who asks he's asking about the
commercial valuations on hmos um what
are the things i can do to ensure i get
a commercial valuation on my four-bed
terraced to six-bed hmo eg add extra
stoves on tweets etc um
so the first thing is is
why do you want to get a commercial
valuation because personally if i'm
adding value to a property whether it be
a hmo or any property
the idea of wanting a high value is so
that i can then borrow against the new
value and pull my money out so i'm
assuming that that's what you're wanting
to do but i'd love to know a little bit
more about what the plans are with the
property so
there are lenders that will look at
doing commercial valuations on six bed
hmos that's kind of the minimum that
they will do commercial evaluations on
and the as you say the the rooms need to
be on suite rooms if it's bigger than
that if it's like seven eight beds then
very standard it will be commercial
valuations so the first thing i would do
is if you are determined that you want
to get a commercial valuation is i would
speak to a mortgage broker someone that
brokers all the different types of loans
on properties and ask them in this
particular area with this particular
house if i do this that and the other
will there be lenders that will give me
a commercial valuation and what will the
rates be
second thing i want to say to you waves
is try and make sure with it being such
a small hmo that the bricks and mortar
valuation alone is also going to be
where you need it to be because let
commercial lenders of hmos will also
bear in mind the bricks and mortar
valuation so
if you need any more help hit me up on
instagram or come along to one of our
free live training programs but exciting
times and hope you do well
all right next question this is harry
harris harry harry says what's the
simplest way to pay the utilities
such as gas electric water and council
tax when you first buy a buy to let and
how do you make these payments during
void periods when doing work or waiting
for a tenant
okay so harry if it is a hmo property
then generally speaking you will be
responsible for paying all of the
utilities
the gas electric the water the council
tax always when the tenants are in or
whether out you all just pay it that's
part of the service for hmos because it
makes it convenient for the tenants to
move in to move out it's simple for them
and they're just paying for a room
if the property is a family home then
you will pay the
utilities and the council tax
when there's no one living in there now
ideally that will be never because
there'll always be someone living in the
property but when what you have to do is
you have to make sure that you take the
meter readings so
when you first buy the property take the
meter readings
and then before you move the first
tenant in take the meter readings uh
also just with as far as the council tax
is concerned just make sure that you
keep a record of when the tenant moves
in and you've got their ist contract and
then that way you can inform the council
as to when the tenant moved in when they
moved out and make sure they don't
charge you when they shouldn't be and
when the tenant moves out take a meter
reading before the next tenant moves in
same story so i mean that's really all
there is to it it's not particularly
complicated it's just something you need
to have your finger on the boss if
there's anything i've missed off in
terms of utilities let me know comment
below and i'll do my best to help
adam says i want to rent an apartment
and do airbnb but i'm having issues
getting a landlord to give me a sublet
lease
that's because a sublet lease doesn't
exist there's no such thing as a sub at
least and if you're asking landlords for
a sublet lease you're going to scare
them away because not only does it not
exist if it did exist it would be
illegal
so adam before trying to secure an
apartment on a sublet lease find out the
actual
technical contract that you're going to
need which will be a company let
agreement that's what you need you're
not subletting the property
subletting is when you have a tenant
that then puts another tenant in
unauthorized
you're
doing a company let a corporate
agreement with the landlord you're
paying them a monthly rent you're not
living there you're not subletting it
it's what hotels do so you need to
really understand the terminology
because otherwise you're going to scare
landlords off
ben parkinson is it possible to take
over a hmo on a rental rent with
existing tenants in it if so how would
you go about it there's two ways you can
go about it first thing that you could
do is you could say to the uh the
landlord look there's six bedrooms
there's three tenants already in and
there's three bedrooms empty
you agree with the landlord what you're
going to pay the landlord and then you
take over the contracts so you say to
the tenants i'm now the new point of
contact and then you renew the contracts
where the tenants are now paying you
and then you then pay the landlord so
that's one method the other method would
be
to just let the
tenants pay continue paying the landlord
but then you just take that into account
and you obviously when you're
reimbursing one another you're just
taking that into account so
every deal is slightly different and if
there's already tenants in it might just
need a little bit more planning and
thought on
where the payments are all gonna go but
this is something that i've done many
times and in fact amelia who did the
financial freedom challenge with me she
took on a property in clapham the
tenants were currently paying the
landlord she took over the property and
it all worked out beautifully fine and
now she's making 850 pounds a month from
the property so yes it happens hope that
helps
june coriet i've inherited a house how
can i use it to start my property
business i have benefactors
um
probably if you've inherited a house the
chances are the house is probably not it
might be wrong but it's probably not
going to happen to be a brilliant
investment opportunity a brilliant
investment opportunity would either be a
house that's got a really super high
rental demand in which case amazing you
should just keep the house maybe
refinance it and rent it out another
brilliant investment opportunity for a
house would be if there was added value
to be done so for instance if the house
had a piece of land at the side of it
that you could potentially get planning
permission on to really increase the
uplift of the property
if the house is just a house
and if you wouldn't buy it now as it is
because it doesn't make financial sense
then it might make sense to just sell
the house and then use the monies to
invest from scratch bothered now says
i'm finding it really hard to raise cash
to get my rent to rent portfolio going
of course i can earn work
but i feel finding and sourcing the
money can be the more beneficial to me
in the long run please any pointers
yes bothered now you are absolutely 100
incorrect finding the money is not the
hard bit finding the money is simple the
hard bit is getting to the point whereby
you need the money i wish i could phone
you up right now guaranteed maybe i'm
wrong if i am you can let me know in the
comments but guaranteed if i rang you
right now and said
i've got 25 grand and i want to give it
to you
what are you going to do with it you
wouldn't have deals and a clear plan and
a clear strategy how you could invest
that 25 000 pounds and really make it
count
so in which case you don't need the 25
grand
you need to get to the point whereby you
need the 25 grand that's the hard bit
and when you get to that point the money
always always comes and it comes easily
speaking from experience
don't worry about the xyz of not having
the money worry about the abc if not
having the deals which we where you
would need the money on all right last
question
mahai says finally i managed to buy my
first brr
property
then i want to in ipswich what is your
recommendation to use an estate agent to
find tenants or to do it by myself what
mistakes should i avoid so great you've
got a brr in ipswich well done so if
you've just bought this property in
ipswich and you're looking for tenants
presumably you've got to the point
whereby you are buy refurbished
refinance rent you know what i'm gonna
tell you a little secret bar refurbished
your finance rent is actually incorrect
that is not the order the order is
actually buy refurbished rent with
finance
because you want to rent the property
out before you refinance it and the
reason is because
it will help your valuation if there's
tenants in the property because the
lender will want to see
what the rent is and it's going to help
the valuation so what i'd say is you
want to make sure the tenants are paying
the highest rent possible
and would i recommend an agent
uh probably yeah sure mistakes that you
could make will be letting a tenant move
in paying too cheap rent and then the
property gets down valued because the
rent is not high enough that i saw that
happen recently with a guy called paul
um i was speaking to him on instagram
and he said that the rent wasn't high
enough what should i do and it's really
difficult so get the rent to pay at
highest rent as possible um use an agent
make sure that you register their
deposit make sure that you have a gas
safety certificate in place um make sure
that the epc you know what the epc is
because these are all things whereby if
you haven't got them on file now and
then the tenant wants to you want to
evict the tenant you can't if you've not
got these things in place now use an
agent by all means and good luck i hope
that valuation comes in what i'd be
thinking about more than anything is
how to put a nice valuation pack
together for the valuer to show that
i've pushed the value up as high as
possible maybe that's for another video
if you've got questions let me know
below and i look forward to seeing you
guys
[Music]